>>Marco: Good afternoon.
Hello, I'm Marco Tempest.
Thank you very much for coming to my short
presentation.
I am a cyber illusionist.
And today I'm going to show you some of the
secrets behind creating magic.
Cyber illusionist, what does that mean?
It means I combine magic and science to create
illusions.
Arthur C. Clark said that "any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable from
magic."
That is true and we magicians have known this
for over two thousand years.
Around 150 BC, Hero of Alexandria described
how the temples of Ancient Greece were filled
with magic.
Others burst into flames.
Door mysteriously opened.
Musical instruments played as if touched by
the gods.
Hero, a mathematician, also explained how
these miracles were accomplished.
They were all magic tricks--applications of
the little-known sciences of hydraulics, pneumatics,
and chemistry.
But to the temple visitors, this was magic.
Now, magic as an entertainment form has long
separated itself from the gods and superstition,
but it has always maintained its relationship
with science.
Magicians are somewhat the original early
adapters of technology.
Whenever we hear about a new development in
science, whether it's physics, optics, chemistry,
or even psychology, we figure out ways to
use it in our magic, keeping one step ahead
of the public and following Arthur C. Clarke's
dictum, "in disguising science as magic."
Magic that we now accept as part of the world
of entertainment.
Now, magic is a very introverted field.
While scientists regularly publish their latest
research, we magicians do not like to share
our methods and secrets.
That's true even amongst peers.
But if we look at creative practice as a form
of research, or art as a form of R and D for
humanity, then how could a cyber illusionist
like myself share his research?
Now my own specialty is combining digital
technology and magic.
And it's about three years ago, I started
an exercise in openness and inclusiveness
by reaching out into the Open Source software
community to create new digital tools for
magic--tools that could eventually be shared
with its other artists to start them off further
along in the process and to get them to the
poetry faster.
I'd like to share with you something that
came out of these collaborations.
It's augmented reality projection tracking
and mapping system.
And I brought it with me.
So, let's have some fun with it.
Let me start it up.
[New Age music]
Wonderful.
Alright.
Now, my creative process always starts with
a blank canvas, which is equally frightening
and equally exciting.
Frightening because of the endless possibilities
and exciting for the same reasons.
But once I commit my first stroke, the adventure
begins.
[drum beats]
[scratching]
[synthesizer notes]
[crash]
Forgot the floor.
Sorry about that.
[scratching]
Alright.
Hey.
Over here.
Ah, no.
This way.
[upbeat synthesizer notes]
[scratching]
Please.
OK, I know what you want.
How about here?
OK.
OK, he got the hang of it.
[laughter]
[drum beats]
[synthesizer notes]
OK.
[crash]
OK, let's try this.
[scratches]
Come on.
Got that at the micro-kitchen.
[laughter]
[flapping]
[bubbles]
Hey.
Go for it.
[kissing noise]
[laughter]
Bye, bye.
Thank you.
[applause]
So, in the spirit of a truly open source magician,
I wanna give you a sneak peak on how the system
actually works.
In front of me is a small projector.
Mounted on the projector is high-speed camera.
And the camera has an infrared pass band filter
attached to it, which enables the camera to
see infrared tracking markers, which are embedded
in the corners of this canvas.
We can add a cookie from that micro-kitchen.
I have a remote control that goes through
a playlist system.
I'm tracking the position of the canvas about
80 to 90 times every second.
And I have this thing, which is the peripheral
illumination, which is very cool.
So, I have a virtual follow spot which illuminates
me but does not interfere with the video image.
I also have a drawing system, a 2-D particle
system, which can sprites and 2-D box physics.
There's a 3-D model loader.
There's like, various things.
So, the tool is very extensible and very easy
to use for different type of productions.
It can be used for projecting onto masks,
pieces of scenery, buildings and such.
It's all created in a tool which is called
Open Frameworks.
It's a C++ library for people who love to
play with multimedia and new media.
Thank you.
[applause]
It may be worth saying something at this point
about the nature of magic.
What is magic?
And why do magic tricks fool us?
Now, magicians are often thought of as being
masters of sleight of hand.
The quickness of the hands deceives the eye.
But that is not true.
Magic does not depend on deceiving the eye.
It depends on deceiving the brain.
The tricks of magicians are not designed to
fool the eye.
The eye observes whatever is put in front
of it.
It's the brain that translates the scene into
information.
And the brain loves to look for patterns in
the environment.
The brain recognizes elements and assumes
that the things he sees now are exactly the
same as the things he has seen before.
Now we magicians take advantage of the brain's
lazy thinking because in a magic trick, nothing
is ever as it seems.
Magicians carefully design their tricks so
everything about them seems familiar.
The props seem ordinary.
The magicians actions above suspicion.
Even the words we use seems straight-forward
and unambiguous.
But this veneer of ordinariness covers many
deceptions.
So, the eye sees everything, but the brain
is being fooled.
Now, let me show you a card trick.
And to make sure that I don't use any sleight
of hand, I'm gonna use some very big cards.
And this is something we can all play along
together.
And if you already know the outcome, play
along anyway.
So, I've prepared five virtual playing cards.
I want you all to remember one of these five
cards.
Remember the suit and remember the value.
And make up your mind now, OK?
Don't forget your card.
We gonna mix up the cards through some magical
touch screen technology.
Yeah, OK.
And I'm gonna remove one of the cards.
How about this one?
This one.
Now, if I was right, then your card is now
gone.
Yeah?
Did that work?
Well, don't worry about it.
Mine actually disappeared, too.
[laughs] Alright.
I'd like to show you another card trick.
I brought something with me.
I'm fascinated with card tricks.
And there's always this dual reality.
That's what goes on for you guys out there.
And then, there's what goes on in the mind
of cyber illusionists if he does something
as simple as a trick with playing cards.
So, I rigged up this contraption, which hopefully
will give you a glimpse.
It can talk too.
Which will give you a glimpse into the mind
of a techno magician when he does something
as simple as a trick with playing cards.
I'm not sure I have enough light.
Is this all the light we had in the rehearsal,
or is there another level of light?
Let's see.
Otherwise, I'm gonna do a little bit of adjustment.
To speed things up, so I have a deck of cards.
I gonna select a card.
Let's take one from the middle just like this.
And then to make sure, this is perfect, thank
you.
And to make sure that we recognize it when
we see it again, I gonna mark it on the front
of the card just like this.
Alright.
Gonna put the card somewhere in the deck just
like this.
And give the cards a quick cut, which is like
this.
Alright.
Now, for those of you don't play cards, a
deck of cards is made up of four different
suits.
[pause]
You know what?
I cannot start this now.
I'm terribly sorry about that.
[pause]
While this starts up, this is also created
in Open Framework.
And I'm purposely using a super cheap camera
on this, which is a PlayStation 3i toy, like
a 30 dollar camera because I have quite a
few very enthusiastic fans which I love to
recreate the kinds of things I do and using
an inexpensive camera makes it much more possible
for them.
Alright.
Let's see.
OK.
So, for those of you don't play cards, a deck
of cards is made of four different suits.
There's hearts, clubs, diamonds, and spades.
[female computer voice]
Performing magic is always about this multiple
layers of reality combining.
Now, each of the four suits corresponds to
one of the four seasons.
There's spring, the summer, fall, and winter.
Mine, too.
Like magic, winter involves visual wonder,
drastic change, and delicate balance between
its physical states.
In each of the four suits--cut--is a total
of 13 cards, which is very interesting.
Over here we have low tides and then over
here, we have high tides.
And then, in the middle, we have the moon.
Hee, hee, hee.
[laughter]
There's two colors in a deck of cards.
There's the color red and the color black.
And they represent the constant changes from
day to night.
In a complete deck of card, there's a total
of 52 cards.
They represent the 52 weeks of a calendar.
One more cut.
Three, six, five.
OK, it's 364 plus the Joker makes it 365,
which is the exact amount of days between
our birthdays.
And what else could I say?
OK.
Get rid of this.
Now so, the cards are somewhat an ancient
calendar.
And with this calendar, I have traveled around
the world, entertaining boys and girls, man
and woman, husbands and wives, kings and queens.
And sometimes--.
Now these guys can be real hecklers.
Watch.
Wake up.
>>Joker: Woah.
>>Marco: Are you ready?
>>Joker: Ready.
>>Marco: Let me see what you got.
>>Joker: Presenting my pogo stick.
>>Marco: Hey, watch out.
>>Joker: Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Ow.
>>Marco: But today, I'm performing for a different
kind of audience.
Today, I'm performing for you.
Let's put this here.
Sometimes people ask me, "Hey, Marco.
To do magic, can you just work from nine to
five?"
Of course not.
I work like everybody at Google.
OK.
24/7 might be a little bit of an exaggeration,
but it does take a lot of time to create magic.
Now, some people will say, "Hey, magic.
That's the work of some supernatural, evil
forces."
[laughter]
OK.
No matter how this looks, to this, I just
say no, no.
OK, in Swiss German, it's nein, nein.
[laughter]
It's really not that intense, but I have to
warn you.
If you ever play with somebody who is so good
with cards, don't play for money because even
if you receive a decent hand, they will be
prepared.
[laughter]
And that leaves me with the last and most
important card of all.
Let's see.
This is, without a question, the real thing.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
OK.
This, again, uses a lot of fancy tracking
and stuff, so if any of you after the presentation
are interested to see a little bit behind
the screens, I'll hold the d-box screens open
and you're welcome to come up here and check
out how the tracking works and all the illusion
and making things disappear into the table
and such.
I'd like to show you one last thing.
It's a piece of software I've been working
on which synchronizes videos across multiple
screens of mobile devices.
It's free.
It's available at the App Store.
Unfortunately, as of today, only on iOS, but
we're working super hard making this work
on Android devices.
I brought these three iPods with me to show
you how it works.
And I'm gonna use them to tell you a little
bit about my favorite subject, which is deception.
Let's keep this up.
OK.
[laughter]
Yeah.
Deception.
One of my favorite magicians is Karl Germain.
He had this wonderful trick where a rosebush
would bloom right in front of your eyes.
But it was his production of a butterfly that
was the most beautiful.
Ladies and gentlemen, the creation of lights.
[children cheer]
When asked about deception, he said this,
"Magic is the only honest profession.
A magician promises to deceive you and he
does."
I like to think of myself as an honest magician.
I use a lot of tricks, which means that sometimes,
I have to lie to you.
I feel bad about that.
[laughter]
But people lie every day.
[phone rings]
>>Woman: Hey, where are you?
>>Marco: I'm stuck in traffic.
I'll be there soon.
We've all done it.
>>Woman #2: I'll be ready in just a minute,
darling.
>>Man #1: It's just what I've always wanted.
>>Woman: You were great.
[laughter]
>>Marco: Deception.
It's a fundamental part of life.
Now, polls show that man tell twice as many
lies as a woman, assuming the woman he asked
told the truth.
We deceive to gain advantage.
And to hide our weaknesses.
The Chinese General Sun Tzu said that all
war was based on deception.
Oscar Wilde said the same thing of romance.
Some people deceive for money.
Let's play a game.
Three cards.
Three chances.
One five will get you ten.
One ten will get you 20.
Now, where's the lady?
Where is the queen?
This one?
Sorry, you lose.
[laughter]
I didn't deceive you.
You deceived yourself.
Self-deception.
That's why we convince ourselves that a lie
is a truth.
Now, sometimes it's hard to tell the two apart.
Compulsive gamblers are experts in self-deception.
They believe they can win.
They forget the times they lose.
The brain is very good at forgetting.
Bad experiences are quickly forgotten.
Bad experiences quickly disappear, which is
why in this vast and lonely cosmos, we are
so wonderfully optimistic.
Our self-deception becomes a positive illusion.
Why movies are able to take us on extraordinary
adventures.
Why we believe Romeo, when he says he loves
Juliet.
And why single notes of music, when played
together, become a sonata and conjure up meaning.
That's Claire de Lune.
It's composer Claude Debussy said that art
was the greatest deception of all.
Art is a deception that creates real emotions--a
lie that creates the truth.
And when you give yourself over to that deception,
it becomes magic.
Thank you,
[applause]
We have already reached the end of my short
presentation.
Thank you very much for coming.
If you have any questions, we have two microphones
which are open right now.
I'm glad to answer most of the things you
might wanna ask.
Also, if you're interested in some of the
technology, I have the stuff up on stage so
that you can play with it as well.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Alright.
Well thank you very much.
Thank you.
[applause]